a week after prime minister boris
johnson said humanity is reaching a
turning point on climate change there's
been a warning that people's anxiety
levels over the issue is reaching an
all-time high could scaring people too
much end up preventing them from taking
action
how do we find that balance how should
we deal with climate anxiety alice
well the way we talk about climate is
something i'm very preoccupied with how
do we tell this story and how do we make
people feel um
powerful and and not powerless i'm not
sure i have the answer but should we be
concerned about eco anxiety 100
um and i would say that feeling anxiety
in the face of headlines like you know
the ipcc's red code for humanity
scientists telling us untold suffering
is coming down the line if we don't take
action these are entirely rational
responses to the information um that we
are learning i'm hearing about the rise
of climate cafes across the uk sort of
workshop therapy sessions for the young
people and and i i can't help but think
about you know not so long ago young
people when they thought about the
future um it was a future of flying cars
and and now it's
one that is very dystopian but we have
to talk not only about the sacrifice and
not only about the dystopia but also
about the opportunities that we have to
build a better and fairer and greener
world
as you mentioned there alice young
people certainly are the demographic
that are going to have to deal with
climate change for longer and the
demographic that are more concerned
about it 56
of young people according to a recent
poll think humanity is doomed david how
would you reassure them
i think the opportunities are there to
make sure the future is much more
comfortable and much more attractive
than the one they imagine reading the
climate science headlines that's because
dramatic change is quite possible it's
not because the climate science is
um
you know being presented in a too scary
manner that is what the science says we
don't change course we don't take action
the world will not resemble the one that
our parents and grandparents and great
grandparents lived in um the
what we would have to do to live
comfortably in that world is far beyond
our imaginations and we have to take
seriously just how urgent the crisis is
if we hope to respond to it for those
who worry about climate anxiety i think
it is real for people who are
preoccupied with the subject but i also
think it is a motivator i think if we
look at the last few years um after the
ipc's 1.5 degree report we saw the rise
of brother tinberg and the
school strikers we saw the rise of
extinction rebellion in the us we saw
the rise of sunrise and all of global
climate geopolitics has changed in the
aftermath of those protest movements
which were motivated by fear they also
offered positive visions of the future i
think those are important too but they
were driven primarily by anxiety i think
we should respond to how scary the
science is by mobilizing not by um
collapsing into despair but i think we
have to take seriously just how urgent
the science says the matter really is
and alice where would you strike the
balance just briefly before we let you
go uh the chair of the climate change
committee said if you scare the if you
scare the public you don't get people to
act do you believe that's true
uh i think that
as david says it's it's a motivating
factor for me action is the antidote to
anxiety so you know many of us may act
from fear um it is
not so productive to act from a place of
fear so how can you transform that
emotion into something productive
be an activist whatever that means to
you it doesn't necessarily mean standing
out on the street in protest um it means
different things to all of us but find
what you're good at find what you can
contribute to the movement and play your
part
you